[Music]
do
[Music]
the consciousness that judges in this
way is itself base
because it divides up the action
producing and holding fast to the
disparity of the action with itself
further it is hypocrisy because it
passes off such judging
not as another manner of being wicked
but as the correct consciousness of the
action
setting itself up in this unreality and
conceit of knowing well and better above
the deeds it discredits and wanting its
words without deeds to be taken for a
superior kind of reality
by putting itself then in this way on a
level with the doer on whom it passes
judgment it is recognized by the latter
as the same
as himself this ladder does not merely
find himself apprehended by the others
something alien
and disparate from it but rather finds
that other according to its own nature
and disposition identical
with himself perceiving this identity
and giving utterance to it he confesses
this to the other and equally expects
that the other
having in fact put himself on the same
level will also respond in words in
which he will give utterance to this
identity
with him and expects that this mutual
recognition will now exist in fact
his confession is not in a basement a
humiliation
a throwing away of himself in relation
to the other for this utterance is not a
one-sided affair which would establish
his disparity with the other on the
contrary he gives himself utterance
solely on account of his having seen his
identity with the other
he on his side gives expression to their
common identity in his confession
and gives utterance to it for the reason
that language is the existence of spirit
as an immediate self he thereby expects
that the other will contribute his part
to this existence
paragraph 666 continues this dialectic
between what we can call the at this
point
judging consciousness which is the
universal consciousness we've realized
that this is
not actually a universal consciousness
but rather a consciousness
of the universal in in the previous
paragraph that was an important
transformation that took place you could
say it's a
consciousness that speaks on behalf
of the universal that co-opts the
universal that takes it over and we can
call this the beautiful soul
we can also as we saw last
paragraph in 665
we can call it the valet the comardeener
the
uh chamber servant who looks
at their their master the hero
not as a hero but rather as
somebody who's basically like the rest
of us but puts on heirs
or lives a privileged life or
is you know being given all sorts of
let's call it prestige and passes
but really is just like the rest of us
eating and putting on clothes and
picking their nose and doing all these
base things he's also called it the base
consciousness neither right pulling
things
downward so we've got this judging
consciousness
on the one side the one who is engaging
in judgment
and not acting but just
judging the action of the other
consciousness which we can call the
acting
individual consciousness we can also if
we want to appropriate the
discussion of the valet and the hero
from the previous paragraph we can say
that this is actually the hero
this is a heroic or to some degree
noble consciousness now does that ring a
bell
thinking back in spirit did we have a
dialectic
between the noble and the base
consciousness
playing itself out yes we did in fact
in an earlier part of spirit in this
case the base consciousness the judging
consciousness
is the beautiful soul who
says things and thereby thinks that
they're doing
something even though they're not really
doing anything
and what's going on in this particular
paragraph is a very interesting turning
point that allows us to see
the acting consciousness as
possessing or we might even say to use
one of the terms that hegel is going to
use here
expressing you know
performing a certain kind of
nobility of character and now notice
here that nobility is not something
that one has just within oneself that's
the way the beautiful soul thinks about
itself right
oh i'm so wonderful goodness is inside
of me
the acting consciousness acts and it
does
things that are to some degree
good they are fulfilling duty flicked
moral obligation right and we saw in the
previous paragraph that any
action that you take can be looked at in
a number of different ways
right there's a many-sidedness to action
not only are actions complex by
themselves
but you can also look at the motives
of the action and judge them from
a number of different perspectives many
of which would would make the acting
individual
look evil boozy look look bad
look motivated by selfishness rather
than by
by goodness and what hegel is doing here
is setting us up
for a couple things that are going to
happen as we're concluding
this section of spirit
so one of these is the
acting consciousness becoming aware
of the judgment that is being made
against them
now it could protest as it did in or
as we would say persist uh bihar
right as it did in previous paragraphs
and say
no i'm doing the right thing i've got my
own law inside of me
uh who are you to judge me at this point
it doesn't do that though
at this point it it reaches out towards
the other
and it says well you know you've
actually got something right
you're actually on point
in how you're judging me
and that's part of what makes it good
part of what makes it
noble we could even say that there's
something
like an aspect of duty to
take into account the judgments of other
people
in so far as those judgments have
any any truth to them and remember that
for hegel
truth is not a simple simplistic
thing right so that's a lot of a lot of
preamble to what's going on here i do
want to jump to the very end
of this relatively short but but very
important and dense paragraph
and talk about what's what's supposed to
be happening
but isn't actually happening so you
notice that i've got up here
this reference to language as the
existence
of spirit which is where this this
paragraph
is ending he says
he's telling us what this this acting
consciousness is doing
and says it gives utterance to it for
the reason
that language is the existence of spirit
as an immediate self and then it goes on
he therefore expects the other will
contribute his part to this
existence so we're getting to
in the next couple paragraphs a lot of
discussion about
the the meaning and existence of
spirit of geist right and this is of
course
the phenomenology of spirit and this
is the spirit section of the work the
longest portion of the work with reason
uh being the second longest we're about
to go into the religion
section so something should be happening
here we should be coming to
a a close and a conclusion
about the nature of spirit
hegel is telling us that spirit geist
again has existence dazan
has being there within
we could say the world but not a world
that's unpeopled
it's within a social world a world of
others you know this the whole dialectic
here has been
dialectics of self-consciousnesses that
are aiming
at mutual recognition which is not
happening
at this point but really ought to be
happening at this point going all the
way back to the
master slave dialectic and the you know
two
self-consciousnesses confronting each
other and trying to
have that struggle to the death and all
these developments
what spirit has been looking for in the
medium of
us self-consciousnesses has been
a mutual recognition
you know an honor canon of each other
knowing a being cool with a
celebrating what however we want to put
it right and that is being
basically set up at this point
but it's going to fail at this point as
well and there's an important
transition that's taking place here in
an attitude or action a kind of
action handled right that is taking
place on the part
of the acting individual
and so they're not just acting they're
also
doing something in the medium of
language
here spraka right and hegel is using a
couple different
language words here he uses the term
veda
discourse right raiden actually the the
verb turned into a noun language spraka
he's talking about
expressing he's this is all happening
through the medium
of engaging with the other
linguistically so it's not just
thought on both sides judging
consciousness of course is
engaged in thinking it's not just
willing and acting
on the part of the acting individual
it's
also speaking with the other
communicating
with the other engaging in a kind of
hopefully communion
but at least communicating and that's
happening through another c
word confession c word in english right
in in german uh gestennis
saying to the other yeah you've actually
got something right i'm not
as good as i'd like to be
your judgments of me they might not be a
hundred percent
accurate but i feel them
within me the rightness the truth that
they do in fact possess
and i'm reflecting that back to you and
saying yeah yeah i i
am bad in some respects my actions
have not been as pure as
one might pretend them to be i do have
motives
that that are selfish or that i need at
least to examine
maybe i'm not even sure what my motives
are you accused me in the previous
paragraph of seeking fame because the
things that i did
actually made me famous maybe there's
something to that
and so this is a reaching out to the
other the other who is judging one
that's that's a tough thing to do isn't
it
and actually before we go into the text
itself
i want to say one other thing about
about this
especially as we're getting to the end
of this spirit section that i think a
lot of people
maybe forget as we're going through the
phenomenology
and i'll probably need to reiterate this
point as we get closer to the very end
of the spirit section
the dialectic that is taking place is
not
one that is driven by
necessity in the sense that everybody
once they reach a certain stage must you
know inevitably
move on to the next stage if you're at
this shape of consciousness
or this conflict of shapes of
consciousness you must
then you know go down this path hegel is
saying
that's what's happened but he's not
saying that's what's happened in every
case
it's possible to remain locked in here
it's possible for things to go off the
path
of the dialectic and then circle around
and come back to
some previous state of the dialectic and
get
stuck there it's it's these are all
possibilities
hegel's not discussing that he is
narrating
as a phenomenologist what is what is
happening
in this particular set of developments
so some people could stay stuck here
forever right and they could stay stuck
here forever
in in either side of this so
that's that's very important to keep in
mind one other proviso i need to get
into so you notice i've got here glycote
and unglychite
these are terms that are being used
in the german text and we've talked
about this quite a bit in in other
commentaries on other videos other other
other
paragraphs that glyce
can be equality it can also be likeness
it can also be similarity
it can be in this case finding the other
the same
as oneself right it's it's establishing
equivalence is another way
and then unlike height is the the
opposite of that disparity is a way to
translate it
inequality um non-identity
these are all there and they are all
being mediated through
language language is where
these are coming to light all right so
let's let's jump into the text now so he
says the consciousness that judges
in this way judges in what way as the
valet
judging the hero everything we've seen
in the previous paragraph
the judging consciousness there's no
action which it could not oppose to the
universal aspect of the action the
personal
aspect of the individuality thereby
playing the part of the moral valet
towards the agent the acting
consciousness so
the consciousness that judges in this
way is
itself base needed like to get
pulling things down because it divides
up the action right it turns the action
into
what is being done the motives for it
and these are made different from each
other
and it's emphasizing the difference this
is this is a choice
on the part of the judging consciousness
so he says
it it produces and holds fast to the
disparity
of the action with itself so the action
cannot be
whole the action cannot be
an integral composite
instead there's there's moments of it
that are being
opposed to each other at least in the
thought
and in the language of the judging
consciousness
and that's something you can do with any
action really i mean
at any point we don't even have to be at
this stage in the dialectic
anybody can do that at any time plato
pointed that out
in talking about how any you know
instance of justice just turn it a
little bit
and you can find some injustice in it
that's an un glyce that's a disparity
there right
so he goes on and he says further it is
hypocrisy we saw this before the one
who's accusing the other of hypocrisy
is themselves a bigger hypocrite than
the first hypocrite was
it's a hypocrisy because it passes off
such judging
not as another manner of being wicked
but
as the correct consciousness of the
action right it's saying that it
has the correct consciousness of the
action it understands what's going on
and he says setting itself up in this
unreality
and conceit of knowing well and better
above the deeds it discredits and
wanting its words without deeds to be
taken for a superior
kind of reality now that's that's well
worth
lingering on right hegel is using
language here of like being on the same
level
and if we want to think about this the
judging consciousness has
actually placed itself on a higher level
in its own mind
than the acting consciousness right the
universal is higher than the particular
we could say
but in reality the the
acting consciousness is better
in some respects than the judging
consciousness in what respects
well in that it engages with reality
it engages with actions it wills
it acts it behaves right that's handled
you can say in german it comports itself
and it doesn't just do so at one moment
it does so over and over again
it persists it perseveres it makes
something
of itself in its relation to the world
and in its relation to
others it takes a risk it we
if we want to you know play around a
little bit it existentially commits
itself
whereas this judging consciousness over
here
it's got things very backwards doesn't
it
he says that
here we go setting it itself up in this
unreality when we're clicking and
conceit
of knowing well and better above the
deeds that it's discrediting and that
it's judging to be
bad and it wants its words
without deeds in this case
raiden discoursing without
doing anything you know being all talk
and no do
as we used to say it wants this to be
taken
as the superior reality now taken as the
superior
reality by by who well by itself it's
trying to convince itself of that it
also wants the acting
uh consciousness to recognize that and
it wants the society you could say the
larger matrix
of others to the other and itself
to acknowledge this as well it wants
spirit
to take it seriously and spirit won't
take it seriously
this is one of the geniuses of hegel
the the recognition and i don't mean
recognition in honor kennen
i mean recognition as in becoming aware
of the fact
that it's really on the side of the
acting consciousness
the one who does the one who risks the
one who
particularizes and determines
and thereby you know makes things real
very clear
it's on that side that spirit
lies not just in a whole bunch of
you know ideas hegel's not an idealist
in that sense
a lot of people paint him that way but
that's just because they're kind of lazy
they're they're not actually reading
ankle or they're
relying on sort of uh glosses that make
themselves feel good
and they're like the judging
consciousness of the guy hegel
who actually did the work to you know
come up with these ideas
let's go on so he says putting itself
then in this way on a level with the
doer on whom it passes judgment it's
recognized by the latter as the same
as himself so the there's the judging
consciousness is
is engaging in some sort of you know
grasping of the acting individual
judging them but the acting person is
also
grasping the judging consciousness the
judge in consciousness is
a self-consciousness which exists in
relation to an other
and more is happening on the side of the
acting consciousness
he says here we go
this ladder the acting consciousness
does not merely find himself
apprehended by the other as something
alien framed
right and disparate wouldn't like
from it but rather finds that other
according to its own nature and
disposition identical with itself now
this is a really interesting phrase here
so the judging consciousness is grasping
the
the disparate the disparity between
itself
and the acting consciousness
but the acting consciousness finds the
other to be the same
as it finds something of the other
already in itself
we saw this before with the you know
dialectic within the acting person of
the individual and the universal within
them
so this is how they can take the
judgment and say yeah i guess
maybe you're right about some of that
and you know
i'm going to reach out to you and take a
double risk i'm not only taking a risk
by acting i'm actually taking another
risk by saying yeah man you're right
so it finds the other the same according
to as he says it's nature or disposition
and this is interesting because these
are both translating the same
term bashafen height the way
you know when we talk about somebody uh
being made
a certain way or i was born that way and
we talk about like temperament or
orientation or stuff like that that's
that's kind of like what hegel's talking
about is bashafen height here
although i guess we could also think
about how we make ourselves and how
we're made
by those around ourselves so it's not a
pure identity
that's the like height here right it's
it's a it's an identity of sameness
but also recognizing difference of of
how we are so he says perceiving this
identity giving utterance to it right so
so it perceives this identity
with the other it expresses or
gives utterance to it it speaks it out
he confesses this to the other
and then equally expects so this is not
a
you know this is not a i'm uh
going to confess and there's a power
differential between us
and i'm a miserable worm or something
like that it's actually being honest
it's it's being real so he goes on he
says
he confesses this to the other and
equally expects that the
other having in fact put himself on the
same level
will also respond in words medium of
language
right in which he will give utterance to
this identity
with him and he expects that this mutual
recognition
will now exist in fact there's a there's
a chance
here to have mutual recognition
right and so that's why this confession
which when we hear the word confession
we usually think about you know legal
stuff
or we think about religious stuff and
either way we're like oh man if you
confess to the cops you're in trouble
right you're going away to the clink and
that's going to be a problem for you
or we're like oh you're confessing to
somebody else i suppose we might also
talk about it in in other rhetorical
forms as well but it's usually like
making oneself less
by confessing this is one reason why
people don't like to confess things
right
they don't like to be made less hegel
specifies here that
because there's this expectation that
the other is going to reciprocate
and thereby engage in recognition
of the person who's confessing
that this is not a this is not a
lowering of oneself so he says that
this utterance is his confession is not
in a basement right
it's not a need lowering oneself it's
not a humiliation
the mutigun right it's not a like you
know oh
i'm so bad sort of confession right
and he also says it's not a throwing
away of himself
in relation to the other it's not a
vague in helpness
andre right so it's it's not
throwing oneself away it's actually
putting oneself in front of the other
in openness in honesty in
an attempt to reach out to the other and
to recognize the other and expect
recognition in return so this is a very
powerful action not a reacting
consciousness will necessarily do that
some of them might be like
judging consciousness go screw yourself
you know i'm gonna do what i'm gonna do
and i don't care well that's an earlier
stage in this this dialectical
advancement
but it is possible this is where
responsibility comes in this is very
this is very much an existentialist
hegel is it not i mean this could be
said by
somebody like simone de beauvoir all
right or
albert camus but it's being said by
hegel at this point
so he says this utterance is not a
one-sided affair which would establish
disparity
again unlike height with the other on
the contrary he gives himself utterance
solely on account
of his having seen his identity with the
other
he on his side gives expression to their
common identity in his confession
now here we come to the end and gives
utterance to it for the reason that
language is the existence of spirit as
an immediate self
he thereby therefore expects that the
other
will contribute his part to to this
existence of spirit something bigger
than both of them when genuine
confession
in this sense is taking place we might
even use a different word
for it you know to describe this
openness and honesty in relation to the
other this
here i am i'm i'm acting i'm responsible
for what i do
i invite you to do the same with me you
know in reciprocal
recognition that's that's creating
something that's that's bigger
than just the individuals themselves
and now this person over here on this
side is like okay come on
your turn and that's where the paragraph
ends
you